alors l'académie de médecine a publié
aujourd'hui un avis au sujet du port du
masque en population ça il s'agit bien
ici du masque grand public
elle indique que pour être efficace le
port du masque anti-projections doit
être généralisé dans l'espace public que
cette mesure ne peut avoir un impact
épidémiologique c'est à dire sur
l'épidémie sur la circulation du virus
que si tout individu s'astreint à
l'appliquer dès qu'il sort de son
domicile etc attendre la date du 11 mai
pour porter le masque c'est accorder
encore trois semaines de répit ou virus
pour qu'il continue de se transmettre
et c'est accepter des désinfections
supplémentaires et des hospitalisations
je tiens ce soir à rappeler en premier
lieu et les françaises et les français
ont parfaitement compris que les mesures
les plus efficaces
aujourd'hui pour réduire la vitesse de
l'épidémie c'est le respect du
confinement première rappelle très
important et c'est vraiment encore un
grand merci aux françaises et aux
français qui respecte le confinement
parce que c'est tout simplement la seule
façon de réduire fortement le nombre de
nouvelles infections le nombre de
nouvelles admissions hospitalières
deuxième point c'est le respect de la
distanciation au physique et social
c'est ce que nous devons faire et c'est
ce que nous devrons faire après le 11
mai il faudra encore être très attentif
à encourager le télétravail à faire
attention aux distances et à éviter
d'avoir trop de contacts entre personnes
et troisième rappel les gestes barrières
que nous avons appris à connaître et que
nous avons appris à appliquer et donc
tous ces éléments confinement
distanciation physiques et sociales et
gestes barrières permettent de façon
combinée de freiner la propagation de
l'épidémie et de gêner la transmission
du virus le masque grand public que nous
encourageons fortement
c'est un complément c'est un complément
au bon respect des gestes-barrières le
premier ministre a été très clair
dimanche il a insisté sur le fait que
les masques grand public ne remplaceront
jamais les gestes barrières que porter
un masque grand public et considérer qu
on peut donc s'affranchir de tout le
reste
on peut toucher les gens qu'on peut s'en
rapprocher qu'on peut éviter de tousser
dans son coude qu'on peut éviter
d'utiliser des mouchoirs et d'éviter de
se laver les mains est potentiellement
une fausse sécurité et c'est ce que
rappelle non pas simplement le premier
ministre mais aussi des autorités
scientifiques et l'organisation mondiale
de la santé
donc il n'y a rien de contradictoire
avec la position des autorités
sanitaires
j'ai toujours plaidé pour le l'accès aux
masques grand public et vous avez qu'il
ya un effort très important qui est fait
par l'ensemble des industriels français
qui vont monter à un rythme de
production de ces masques grand public
qui sera de 17 millions par semaine à à
l'horizon du 11 mai nous aurons aussi
des importations massives ce sont des
masques lavables ce sont des masses
réutilisables ce sont des matches pour
lesquels nous avons fait des efforts de
normalisation qui ont été testées il
faut que nous apprenions tous ensemble
aussi
cet ensemble de mesures qui nous
permettront de lutter contre la
diffusion du virus car il y aura encore
de la circulation du virus
après le 11 mai il faut apprendre à le
poser à l'adapter correctement à son
visage à couvrir absolument et c'est
très important
le nez et la bouche à savoir l'enlever
et se laver les mains et surtout à ce
qu'on comprenne tous ensemble quels sont
les gestes à risque les situations à
risque et donc nous aurons à développer
tous ensemble une pédagogie collective
pour apprendre aux personnes les plus
vulnérables pour apprendre à notre
entourage pour apprendre à nos proches
l'usagé du masque comme une mesure
supplémentaire comme une mesure
complémentaire à tout ce que nous avons
déjà appris pendant le confinement et
avant c'est-à-dire le respect strict des
gestes barrières la distanciation
physique d'un mètre minimum qui reste
absolument nécessaire et la réduction
des contacts sociaux
lévy